many people ask me questions about stoic
philosophy and practice I've created
this series to provide short answers to
the most common recurring or confusing
questions about stoicism does stoicism
require repressing one's emotions this
is a great question
because it's so reflective of a major
misunderstanding a very widespread one
of what it is that stoic philosophy has
as its basis and what it's advocating
and what the goal or end point of
practicing stoicism is supposed to be
now if you're the sort of person who
wants a quick straightforward simple
answer the answer to this question is no
stoicism does not require repressing
one's emotions that's probably not that
satisfying of an answer because you
might say but I've but I heard that it
did or it seems from the things that
I've read that that's what one ought to
do so we want to look at what stoicism
actually tells us about the emotions
first though I think it's very useful to
make a distinction between lowercase s
stoicism which is a character trait or
disposition of toughness oftentimes
involving repressing emotions not
dealing with them not acknowledging them
that's not what we're talking about here
as uppercase s stoicism the philosophy
and set of practices that go all the way
back to ancient times let's start by
looking at what the Stoics have to say
about emotions in general and there's a
prevalent misunderstanding of them that
says that the Stoics thought all the
emotions were bad you can see people
repeating this in histories of
philosophy in interpretations of
stoicism and that's actually incorrect
if we look at what the Stoics did have
to say about emotions they thought that
many of our emotional responses are in
fact
bad they're negative they they don't
help us they actually are disturbances
of the soul or if you prefer a different
term the personality or the mind but the
Stoics also thought that there are some
emotional responses that are not just
neutral but are in fact good for us to
have they called these the new path AI
and those would be you know things like
rational amount of fear where they
called caution you LA baya rational
desire bool ASIS and they didn't talk
about about you know grief or pain in
that way but they did talk about a
rational type of pleasure sort of joy is
is the way that we could translate that
notice that I'm using the term rational
in all of those this doesn't mean that
we have to be you know totally in our
head and detached from our emotional
life what it means is that there are
certain limits or orientations or
guidelines given by our rational faculty
to how and why we're feeling the way
that we are so the Stoics think that we
should be joyful about some things we
should be cautious about some things we
should in fact feel confidence in some
cases we should in fact have desires now
that doesn't mean that that every single
joy or pleasure is automatically good
but they did distinguish that entire
range some of the others that they do
talk about are what we might call
attachment or familial affection Phil
Astoria Marcus will talk quite often
about about you know all sorts of other
emotions as soul Seneca many of them
will use the term love and in fact the
Stoics did not think that all love is is
necessarily pathological either so
there's a wide range of emotions that a
stoic wouldn't
press even if the Stoics were into
repressing emotions that leaves open of
course the question well what about
those bad emotions shouldn't we just
repress those and the Stoics would say
probably not because when you just
repress you push down an emotion you try
to you know submerge it below the level
of your consciousness or you resist it
and you you won't give in to it
you're not actually improving yourself
you are just taking a stand it could be
good if you're you know finding yourself
very angry to not say that thing that
you want to say but that's not
repressing the emotion that's just not
acting on that emotion to repress the
emotions means to tell yourself I'm not
going to feel this or I'm not feeling it
and you tell yourself that enough until
you actually believe that you're not
angry afraid you know sad whatever it
happens to be this is not a productive
way to approach things because if you do
that you're not changing anything about
the environment that is is you know
having you feel that way you're not
gaining any insight about why your
response to those triggers stressors
events is causing you to feel that
emotion so it's going to keep on
happening over and over and over again
and you're gonna find yourself having to
repress it even more and then it can
become a bad habit
that becomes quite difficult to break so
that's one big reason why it's not
helpful but it also tends to deform you
the idea behind stoic philosophy is
self-knowledge we want to understand
what's going on in our damaged screwed
up selves so that we can selectively
start to work on things and fix it if I
find that I'm really struggling with
anger it's not going to do me any good
to repress it I need to know why I'm
angry when I'm getting angry what it is
that I'm getting angry over I need to
look at my reactions and be honest with
myself perhaps even bring in a coach to
get somebody else to give me some
honesty only then can I begin to work
on those emotions so that I will feel
them less or less often or less
intensely or perhaps not even feel them
at all
that's what stoicism is suggesting in
terms of the disturbing emotions so it's
clear that we don't want to repress
emotions in stoicism where might you go
if you want to learn more about the
Stoics and emotion well there's
classical sources and I would actually
direct you to Cicero's Tusculum
disputations today I'd nasal air tease
lives of the philosophers book 7 chapter
1 about Zeno and the doctrines of the
Stoics and two arias did a mrs. epitome
of stoic ethics I would also read around
in Seneca in Epictetus and in marcus
aurelius and you're gonna find lots of
great discussions Seneca in fact has an
entire book on anger which could be very
helpful for you to read and there
happens to be one excellent contemporary
work by a scholar
on this very topic it's Margaret graver
and her stoicism and emotion it's a
somewhat difficult book it's written for
an academic audience but it's pretty
readable and she is dead on in her
analyses of the Stoics in their
discussions of emotion if you found this
answer helpful for you then please share
it with others who might benefit from it
this work is entirely supported by
crowdfunding on my patreon site so if
you find it valuable consider becoming a
supporter at patreon.com slash Sadler